le
[Musique]
je ne réveille pas de plaisir gino
savard est générale et notamment la
ferrage de charcot n'est qu'une chambre
j'étais les joueurs de ma part et le
talent autrefois largement celles là
sont mangés nord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est comment fait la bulle les
normes sont achetés qui attend 160
d'abord
[Musique]
sont donc je demande à l'eau alors oui
ils ont dû faire prescrire et prévoit
que la tête la maison notamment par la
maison tu n'écoutes pas et là tu veux
que je te fasse une mêlée bleue est
reconnu comme un vide pour la tête sur
mon et donc flat trouvait alors approché
je peux avait pressé la chine d'ici là
où ça souffle c'est bon bien sûr on va
aller ensemble
alors
[Musique]
alors là je vais voir mes amis on va
boire un coup ensemble à maison
travaille pas et la veut mettre les
faits en finir une bonne fréquentation
comme ça alors il rassure pas mal du
tout est là mais ça va manquer les
pannes est lui manquait de peu sa jupe
[Musique]
donc en fait fugué d'un état fort qui
dit harkis jocelyn thibault à l'égard du
coup d'état faisait alors qu un monde
juste des tapas que son balcon deux
camps sont là pour bloquer coécrit et
déjà les stops asie allez circulez sûr
qu'ils aient circulé
bonjour junior le carnet s'il te plaît
non mapaq en ce moment tu écoutes tu
sais très bien qu'ils aient un règlement
il faut arriver moi il m'a montré autant
c'est comme ça ça a toujours été comme
ça il faut garder en tête que le limite
ce matin était une audience aussi ce
texte et ce sont des rousses qu'on
rentre il a k'un l'odieux consumant a
quand même envie de passer mais on
attend et satisfasse là c'est quoi ces
manières de parler navires d'atteindre
son mentor qu'il parle pas comme ça et
puis dans leur parle comme un nom vous
là où les panneaux et un an mal an mais
parfaitement normal non on crie ou sans
insulte simplement c'est pas ce qu'on
fait d'habitude encore une belle jeter
leur fin est revenu au monsieur monsieur
vrai au calme est ok mais celle
d'éléments votre adresse il vous plait
numéro de téléphone ne connais pas ok
voulait pas coopéré vous allez me suivre
pour ça les sportifs
[Musique]
alors voila voila un guichet fils vous
expliquer je reprends ce qu'il a dit un
nouveau proviseur s'est plaint d' état
d'ébriété mais aussi de l'odeur suspecte
de zamal conserve un niveau bas déjà
c'est bien que vous vous reconnaissez
que vous consommez pas mal vous
reconnaissez que vous avez un problème
avec cette addiction
ça c'est votre vie ce que je veux vous
faire comprendre c'est que aujourd'hui
la balle est dans votre camp soit vous
décidez de vous en sortir
je donne des contacts pour vous en
sortir au niveau de l'addictologie vous
allez être suivi vous aurez des rendez
vous à vous aurez un suivi si vous
voulez pas vous en sortir si vous parlez
de tisanes si vous continuez à consommer
qui est un problème là je dis vous allez
un des problèmes est que la justice donc
aujourd'hui pour vous comprenez que
c'est vous qui allez décider
est ce que vous voulez vous en sortir ou
est-ce que vous l'a aggravée l'autre ktb
que ce manga nous parcourons le premier
je vous donne les contacts de ce centre
[Musique]
d'addictologie d'accord depuis que vous
y retrouve plus
[Musique]
mis à l'eau ce qui alors il s'est juste
je divorce a été baladé rangea mollahs
est organisée jamais devant la police
municipale ont assoupli leurs deux
complices viennent quel est le nouveau
gta là vous dérange à morlaàs ni bail
[Musique]
que je n'avais plus rien dans la case au
mois comme un respect au codm out frère
ou là de dieu
les rouges se l'est fait mal quand
mezzana les chinois tout en poussant
sous la main tout en février que le sens
moral
ces géniaux roi comme encore été en tant
que maman tu es tu encore en alabama -
maraîchers pas combien de mois était
parti pêcher vraiment
en
[Musique]
non
alors quand même un peu moins tout le
monde à moi c'est ta guitare on a le
temps alors messieurs au fond du car
mais bon il va s'incarner man mais bien
en finance à moi et bien mais nous
allons enfin pu changer ce débat va
aller danser le monde est ici
mais par contre pour le collapsus la
nation avant ma naissance
tu étais pas je savais pas que c'était
venu à bord lors d'une amie nadine alors
oui et bien même à main quand tu nous as
du match joué dans son coeur faut pas
pousser dernier team usa premier vol en
fait en train de tenir leur base et nous
laisse aller
[Applaudissements]
arrivé de monnaies comme le match pour y
arriver elle aussi changer ça changera
d'étape alors ça et sa forme du lâchage
non
[Applaudissements]
discrètement une soirée mondaine qui a
tendance à retarder mois
autour du thème un jour georges ont dit
non il
[Musique]
ça n'arrive pas qu'aux centres
auray affrontons b
m
cette annexion n'est pas une fiction
il faut retrouver la clarté son tour
cette obscurité
[Musique]